[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to game of spot
live my name is Sam and joining me today
is the lovely Alana Pierce hi and the
one and only Greg Miller what's up
everybody today we're gonna be playing
some Assassin's Creed Odyssey brought to
you by Ubisoft I wanna jump right into
it yeah jump right into it you're a huge
Assassin's Creed fan I am I've played
all of them too in Brotherhood of my
favorite but then I very much liked what
they did with I guess there's just not
new game
yeah yeah you're stopping you started
right from the beginning oh and guys if
you're in the chat please ask away
on YouTube I will be reading your
questions and passing them off to Alana
and Greg as we play know what I was
saying yes I really liked what they did
with origins and Odyssey seems to him
just like added on that a bunch so I put
in like six or seven hours stuff I think
you play a fair bit more than me yeah
I'm like 1820 hours and so like that
yeah that's a lot of video game there's
a lot of it in this game just scratching
the surface
yeah that's been huge I think yeah
argent struck me like 60 hours to finish
but it's very good and I really like the
setting and I'm gonna play as his name
Alexios Alexius Cassandra is the true
protector that's why I'll be playing as
in an hour very excited yes so we are
playing on xbox one right now Alana is
playing as Alexios and about an hour
Greg is going to pick up where he left
off on his save file that's Cassandra
that's right on the ps4 Pro also worth
mentioning this game literally starts at
the Battle of 300 which i think is super
cool yes and you do get to like spawn
kick people yeah yeah which is pretty
awesome it's like all I've ever wanted
in a video
I mean like honestly how many times have
you like sparked kicked a door open cuz
like that Obama gift yeah yeah I don't
think I've ever done that and I think I
now wipe myself slightly less pointed me
when you get the funhouse office in his
sleeping I'm looking to get back into
Assassin's Creed shape jump back in with
origins or Odyssey I think you can kind
of do either honestly the out of animus
stuff which I don't think we'll touch on
today is linked between the two of them
or just didn't speak like I didn't like
this initial like character any so
jumping into this and falling in love
immediately like when I do get out of
the animus it is very much like I know
there's something's going on here but it
doesn't seem that important so quickly
help a little hop back in and I don't
feel like anything yeah yeah I would say
that it's probably safe to jump into
this game without playing origins yeah I
think so yeah yeah 100 yeah it feels it
honestly you want to talk to people
about it it just seems like are you
eating it Egypt are you into Greece like
that's yeah when I know that layers a
few there's differences in upgrade or
not upgrades but cheese here in terms of
me stuff would have been worried combat
is wait yeah between origins of nada see
yeah really
yeah talk to me about that well we'll
see cuz it'll just introduce my even a
special guy like that is like because I
thought for me the defining thing for
origins was then moving combat up to r1
and like you know putting another
shoulder button on like that it
definitely feels different for me
somebody who just barely touched origins
that basic feeling of it makes more
sense if I were sitting in terms of the
upgrade Trine's yeah Aleya is really
different for hands it's interesting my
impression
of Odyssey has been it improves a lot of
what origins tried to do yeah in some
ways in skilltree the the open world
it's more seamless sure yeah yeah yeah
for me what I keep saying about it right
and I wouldn't say I'm a passing
Sanskrit fan right we're loved to love
Brotherhood alright alright alright
Black Flag I thought was the best
gameplay wise for me this is the best
gameplay that I've ever had in this
series it's the best story I've ever had
in a serious like I really baby I really
feel like every one of the major beats
they build up to in the storyline I'm
like oh my gosh I definitely like it I
don't love it so far really well it'll
be hard for anything to beat Assassin's
Creed 2 coming I think oh yeah I even
liked the story revelations cuz I just
think old man
Altair is so endearing and and it's yeah
but uh yeah I'm liking it and that for
me was that I've not liked Ezio as
through started in a really cool fashion
about oh man I understand I understand
your motivations it's not forever let's
do this but then building the
Brotherhood alright like I don't
remember major points in that where I
feel like he's doing such a great job of
like have you gotten to the final dream
like I thought that was such a great
like this is what you're gonna go do and
I was like that's an awesome oh they
brought up a scrimmage at school and
then accomplishing that task blender the
next revelation was that Billy and it's
like oh man it's actually keeping me
motivated to play through it rather than
just affirm it yes the story is like
really crapping right away it kind of
keeps you in it mmm I felt better than
the previous Assassin's Creed games yeah
so yeah kudos then they did a really
good job with the storytelling and like
I remember dialogue and everything
because I'm in the tutorial right now I
don't know it's uh just X and then Perry
we did I like pairing and this let me
show you walked onto the right guy but
he tries to attack me hey yeah
personally I'm it's been interesting
because I found dodging especially when
it's just one-on-one time time just
dodging okay I've been parenting get
behind it's like Dark Souls in my right
mind it's you know I mean what is ass is
creaking her feet are so it feels like
this game learned from a lot of
different games it brings all different
elements from totally picks there's a
lot of familiarity is different aspects
the game it's interesting when like
Bioware is kind of going away from what
people know if iOS this is taking on
some Bioware trucks which I like a lot
oh sure the ability to have choices in
there you know to actually know the
character a little bit to what you want
it to be yeah I'm gonna try and play
evil this whole time yes just so fun
yeah so that's like one of the
interesting things about this game is
that you can choose if you want to be
good or if you want to be real bad is it
real bad I've been playing you know a
very a just really it's like it's just
like kind of a little bit yeah yeah it's
not like they're you all or anything
like chaotic a though none of that this
is a question that was asked earlier on
in the great is your mic can you I just
did as I pull it out you need to tell me
chat Pittsburgh Greg was punching the
mic someone said yeah and of course the
t-shirt has that loose call it's a
condition let me know the graphics
better okay yeah hopefully it is
improved earlier on they asked what each
of your favorite protagonists have been
in the Assassin's Creed series totally I
see a like in a hobby yeah I mean up
until this point for sure I think your
Sandra's now my way she is really cool
yeah as much time I spend with her I
like how diverse she is I like obviously
part of that is me being able to pick
what she says yeah I mean in leadership
she's just she's just cool it's the
thing like I think she's extremely cool
I just have a big ol crush on this here
seems yes he was better NASA's
brainstorm cool crime says thanks Craig
love you know everything so bigger if
you actually do you want to read it sure
yeah this guy's just so aggressive there
we go
when does the scheming I'm out keeps
doing it luckily there's 15 versions to
pick which one you are I saw birdie
birds tweet up the thing and it's like a
million different us there are many
versions of the game it's out today if
you want to play it's on xbox one ps4
and PC and it looks good and it looks
good if you have an extra pro or a PC
it's very pretty and I feel like the
draw distance is insane I'll go and
synchronize someone just so you guys can
see it may be but it's yes very pretty
have you been using photo Motorhome
I have yeah like it's like one of the
best in thanks yeah is it like the Euro
photo mode kinda kinda feels like
there's been a ton of really cries I was
like I'm doing I've always played racing
game so like back with like Project
Gotham Racing or they always have them
but it's different because racing games
like inherently photogenic yes you know
this you don't have a set it's just a
car and a track or a horizon is like
beautiful game just made it super
different I did a lot Intel there as
well Chris today the stream is going to
go from now until about 4:45 five ish
depending on where we ended right we're
play we're play until we beat it oh god
Stein guys
[Music]
Jonathan says black flag is the only
Assassin's Creed I liked well that's I
think an ich one yeah and this speaks to
that right yes I was gonna say the ship
the ship's the fighting ship stuff in
origins as well but I feel like um
people liked Black Flag so much and it
was people who hadn't traditionally
liked Assassin's Creed that that's why
you'd be stuff is literally making a
pirate game you've got it totally right
here you go some modern a stuff so these
people from origins are saying yeah I'm
I'm pretty sure that's the goal was in
order like I don't really remember her
something but she's cosplaying as a
Robin right from handling it crushing
crushing right now feel like she's
crossed cosplaying is uh Nathan Drake
yeah right yeah get that scoff it was
that one heart of three yeah we desert
Creed now into the mobile animus which
is cool animus text really evolved a lot
city farm yeah yeah that's the thing the
animus concept is really cool oh yeah
hundred Suns
I'm one of the people though who hasn't
minded them moving away from the Animas
the more Temple are Saxony and
Assassin's Creed one and two I was super
invested should me outside Assassin's
Creed to me to wear was like everything
like I was very into that and I hold on
this is a cool thing this right so like
guided mode is that traditional
assassin's creed experience wish with
all due respect beats you over the head
of go there go right there something
that one person wears exploration mode
is their new one right that gives you
like clues and contextual hints in terms
of like it's still pretty easy 100% so
when I chose that I was like it because
it tells you you can go back if you want
to like if you choose exploration you
can change it to guide it and I was like
I don't have the shotgun I've been
playing it like enjoyable yeah yeah
sorry for those of you guys who are
watching exploration mode is basically
like a stripped-down version which
removes markers and quest objectives and
stuff like that yeah like talk to people
in order to be able to find it and
you'll hear it on the map when we're
doing stuff it'll be like oh you know
that this person is west of this
mountain southeast of [ __ ] right look
for this kind of clue about it yeah
probably forces you to really get into
the game and explore about the open
world yeah you know just my mercenaries
know you can like that amount like a
whole so whatever and then you can just
be like go to Makkah like it would be so
easy if you didn't have to do that if
you want like it's probably in this area
because you could just go through
everything like just by pressing a
button so you're like I'm like
counteracting cool
that's awesome also I feel like the
locations on the map are much more
memorable this time around but they all
feel like very distinct yeah they just
said it did a really good job in the
Aces always been very good at that
they've just gotten better with spacing
it now yeah things are spaced apart most
motley and scale is probably better but
like I still feel like I could walk
around Florence and be like yeah here's
got the big choice yeah
oh here we are who will you choose tell
me where we had to make you
Hale Cassandra
she just has such nice biceps she's
distracting unlike Tim oh you got that
vascular bicep yeah it's cars on their
kids yeah she's seen some stuff I'm into
the hair it's like nicely swept yeah
perfectly swept you know and she's like
killing me suspiciously well swept yeah
and it's great all right we're not going
to we're doing him like you used to be
able to run in loading screens now
that's so quick that you don't need to
so here's just like a speculative
question but what do you want the next
setting for Assassin's Creed to be
mm-hmm I still want your pants yeah
everybody says where is it you don't I
mean they listen to us and made the
pirate game yeah everybody like Black
Flag expired stuff so much now let's get
us a drink
that would be awesome yeah yeah I like
can't even think of anything else what
you take it to Australia yeah I don't
know what that would look like
[Music]
so somebody at earlier asked and I
forgot their username it passed guys I'm
sorry how do you feel about fastens
creative really going full RPG I let
coffee jeez yeah me too
then I think about it it's like I think
so far they've struck a great balance
here where it isn't stopping me from
being the action it isn't slowing it
down it is just like okay I'm making the
character exactly more what I want it to
be in that moment right like I you can
invest in being the assassin you can
invest in being warrior and charging and
get everything head-on right makes some
things feel more rewarding like I guess
in like I think it was Brotherhood that
introduced it knows to you have the leg
Villa that you were leveling up and like
[ __ ] always had a PG elements mm-hmm and
that made you know spending money
rewarding and getting your show ups
rewarding where's this has made every
fight rewarding and then it's like a
Diablo style with system so it's like oh
you're gonna go this time what am I like
when you go into your inventory it
reminds me so much of destiny totally
turned a bigger island do this has
better stats different colors yeah yeah
yeah I'm actually very curious I know
right plays cassandra it's like oh so so
basically guys there's no difference in
the story between the two characters
it's kind of just like a
you get to play as a man or a woman and
generally the story is stays the same
yeah I think the dialogue was exactly
the same yes the dialogue is the same so
wonder how hard that is like if they're
writing it that way that the characters
have the same dialogue did they think
about the fact that the different sexes
so they like would they react
differently based on sex like I wonder
if that's even a consideration yeah it
doesn't seem like it it seems like the
reactions are basically says this thing
hey the way they've established I think
because Sandra Dee write is that she is
just as strong and a mercenary just like
yeah so it's not like you'd be like well
what are you gonna do about you don't
Emilio is what she's capable
I need to buy a handbag there's no like
gender bias in the game a lot of people
agree Japan should tell me awesome and
they know this hey you can go so they're
waiting right taking it yeah break again
next year as well maybe it's like Japan
boom mic so sweet I thought the dialogue
was different night that was pretty
shorts I would say exact what is it yeah
um I'm so far okay I roll Oh
does it bother you to be mean in games
do you feel bad ever I don't think ever
doing it in my first playthrough the one
thing I'm really bad about which
sometimes she would get mad at me for is
I'm not good at killing animals if they
aren't an attack that would attract me
right it's not aggressive about it okay
right like it's fine if it's like a
tiger that's trying to kill me but like
if I'm gonna like blow up a total to
make a wallet and fakhr I'm gonna do it
that's like in watchdogs there's a cat I
think that you can go you can cuz you
can kill the cat I watch dogs I've been
pretty sure and paddle the dogs that is
it made me really sad yeah
we're accidentally killing an animal
that you just just what bear or like
that's always terrible to you luckily
all the animals are ferocious in this
game it's yeah pretty much anywhere you
goes like oh here's a freaking line and
won't help yeah yeah the wolves man
they're all about it yeah which was the
first AC to introduce like the caged
animals no I feel like it was bustin
[ __ ] right oh yeah I wonder what the
relationship between him and Makos is
going to be like same thing right it's
surely but it's I'm curious to see so it
was similar do you have Phoebe's men too
yeah she said cor
your choices all right they have an
impact I'm killing them
yeah there you go yeah
Rex crowd saw me man we wore them we
push to the chat into a conversation
about killing animals and video games
it's takes a real dark yeah but I've
always like openly been like I'm really
uncomfortable with it and people like
it's just a video game or like I can't
turn it off yeah it's real to me damn it
these are real here you are your first
of many times yeah yeah punch time in
here I still don't really know what this
is it's just like a little shoulder pad
got a war style sure got a nice a nice
common waist pouch oh I always have a
fanny pack little walk fanny pack
it's my leather OG fanny pack I think I
can go get that fixed
we're already doing that and then we
will slowly unlock something so I just
turn this down a little bit because
we're getting a little echo I guess just
get it sorry
alright I think it's this way stuff I
like said kinda funny cat I'm gonna wish
gamers were to speaker I gotta go
if I know easy to make me uncomfortable
with that if people stare at me for a
long time what's funny in the picture a
picture we're like even closer so I can
be looking at you is even like more
that's pretty good
it's always funny when the picture
picture is swapped and so when you're
shooting at each other you're actually
yeah you know it's the most disturbing
thing of like when you're in trying to
figure out when you're in it and like
you've liked the chat so when I want to
reference some ease chat I put it that
way but it's actually that way you know
Biak one of these directions somebody
said that Cassandra is like a Greek Tomb
Raider and I kind of liked that code see
she's cool I wonder woman yeah yeah
she's one a woman what the what was that
so good
what okay weirdo dogs Esther you nice
see it's actually that's a thing that's
interesting about this game I remember
walking through this pub attacking NPC's
yeah it lets you and it doesn't make you
feel bad about it when I fight back yeah
I got like like GTA style I got into it
I was good taking out one of the bases
or whatever and I accidentally hit up a
screen and they started fighting me
Wallace fighting the guards like man
this isn't about you but okay you have
to die because there's no option for me
to talk it down it's crazy it's also
like if you're on a horse and you run
over someone it just kind of happens
exactly like roll out of the way bird
bird
come on sorry guys I'm not looking up
because I am just reading your comments
yeah that'd be part of it you know I
gotta I'm trying to like you stay
involved the Congress thing I like to
think you'll like just browsing tumblr
I'm just like sometimes like whatever
cry through Twitter you guys do these
idiots it's fine so what have you
thought like the dialog interactions so
far I think it's it's more dynamic than
I expected in it I'm it's it's cool to
play this this time and do things
differently right yeah there's a lot
more personality in them than I expected
it's not just good bad but it's also a
lot of it is complementary to that
exploring ask Laura Torre mode any idea
that you'll be like oh where is it in
what direction is it in so you're like
literally asking people for directions
to get places which I think it's so
they're smart yeah they're like NPCs
that are useful yes I think sky in his
vineyard he's doing it doesn't know
anything about Marcus
I do like funny like there's actually a
lot of like humor built into the
dialogue yeah yeah yes surprisingly yes
surprisingly normally whenever like
games try whenever they try to attempt
to this in writing I had somebody kind
of cringe II hate that I said that I
don't like the friend you were like that
were some games managers like yeah the
nuts are on memes in and I'm good yeah
right so does that like they were like
here's a Josie widow's intro right I
feel like they do such a great job of
giving you your character Marko's and
Phoebe and being like here's how they
all interact and weave together and why
they are there like not family but
they're like a unit totally and it it is
that thing of like okay cool I get it
and I like it even this conversation
here about the winery yeah we're talking
about Riley yeah what you're doing
Markos yeah buddy we spent so much time
with him yeah it's like it's like jokey
it's you know it's good it doesn't say
flashbacks and stuff to like really
really driving home like why these
people are these people yeah yeah you
get a feeling they know each other yeah
for sure yeah it's cool which also I
really feel like the voice acting is
really elevate this one as well compared
to origins yeah I just like I'm
entertained
about the dialogue and that's I think
that's the highest comment you could pay
it right is like last night I was
playing and I was playing this party
scene where like you give away all your
weapons you want you have to get dressed
a certain way and go talk to people and
it when I we got into these things come
I wasn't checking my phone I wasn't like
trying to skip it I was like yeah what
is going on and how do you get you don't
know yeah right I mean I can't wait this
weekend I've been bragging all day to
her this weekend I got nothing to do
well I got ignoring all those things and
I'm just putting on pajamas and playing
else yeah it's about a press conference
anyway the press conference will take
care it's actually a sign of a good game
when you're just like I just want to
forget the rawness we've been doing the
same like when I've been playing and I
haven't been using my phone at all like
I do not like waiting I'm just like wait
yeah yeah
is what long a walk this is a cool
choice to be up here we have a question
at satis is hard yeah I struggled yeah
but this is it this is the choice for
you and there's the three horses in the
stable and so be you have low this one's
great for climbing this one's great for
calming but I need yes exactly but then
also of a crime when you choose it yeah
maybe like ovaries yeah he does it for
everyone so you think you're okay no are
you okay I don't know any no if I change
my choice what doesn't happen I was like
you know I'm not what it did it I went
through every one of them yeah no no you
say this for everything okay cool yeah
great
so combat worse I want a horse that's
this like real aggressive I think that
would be this one which is the most that
I chose courage
now maybe it's alright I think one of
them is okhla metals so this is kind of
a big question but it's been asked how
does this game compared to origins you
can kind of like pick and choose what
comparisons I guess you want to make
that are most important very similar
yeah I think it expands on core concepts
at origins introduced so it's like if
origins refine the series then this
refines origins so it's the off ug
elements are a lot more extensive I
think that you pick up a lot more load
you can break down your loot in like I
think the relationships add an entirely
different dynamic to that you were
talking about combat right that's the
same thing definitely different yeah
it's this what's the same basic idea
shoulder bones all that jazz but it
takes I feel like nothing is
dramatically different everything's just
like a little bit different in a way the
no like 100% yeah and it I know it they
it seemed like they were catching it on
the chin right from the internet
commenter uh well it looks so much like
origins it looks a lot you know to me
like what it sucks they're back to an
annualised format I really feel like it
does look very similar yeah but I just
feel like they did so much right with it
yeah I mean in terms of the fact that
I'm all about it and it's colorful it's
fun it's interesting the character like
I don't know enough about the villains
yet that's the one question I keep
having his other villains interesting
because I liked finding out about all
the villains and origins but then when I
got to the last boss fight I was like
wait why is it this guy shouldn't my
home wait this is despite Todd why am i
fighting you for so long and like here
you still one about like who the bad
guys are and why and again I think the
story beats that I've gone through like
as they set up the next thing it's
because the past ones the Cyclops
oh sure already seen references to
something like already established but
and I love how they do that right where
I really do you feel like they jumped
into this world and people worried about
it being too mythological they do a
great job of introducing yeah character
like the Cyclops right which I think
every time you see him as a monster
whereas here it is just a big dude with
one eye right he's got the eyepatch over
the other one it's like you can see
where this story would be told you know
over hundreds of years and escalate into
this giant mythology thing dad actually
thought about it that way yeah and I
think because they do a couple other
things where they introduce other
characters in a similar format of like
oh I know this character from Greek
mythology
yeah and it's like oh this is
would be modernized but then get into
this mythic mythological status that's
cool
but then again I did no spoilers I did
go to an island as soon as you leave
here and I went down to the basement and
there was like a giant door and this
giant thing shook it it was a Brewer and
she was like my purse and was like I'm
not ready for this yeah I'll come and I
was like III no there's no dousset in
the trailers and stuff i don't know
where the reality of it ends and the
craziness of it begins yeah me too no
totally I am definitely one of the
people who's like I don't need you to
play this historically accurate let's
have fun it's true if you guys are just
joining us we are playing Assassin's
Creed Odyssey well Ilana is currently
playing Assassin's Creed C on xbox alone
and today stream is brought to you by
Ubisoft so if you guys have any
questions we're on YouTube let me know
I'll pass them off you're looking at
that YouTube chat right now I'm looking
at it right now guys reading watching
I'm just killing people you know I know
a lot of both of them no no it's fine
and it's fine
you investigate that I won't even look
what's happened you got it covered up
sure have you guys found any Easter eggs
yet as a question yes but we should
elaborate on this enak I have found
references to you looking at me it's
like previous Assassin's Creed games
cool that's fun that's some fun stuff
because also right now I'm just like
obviously this is just teaching you how
to how that stealth works or anyone who
hasn't played the series before but you
can upgrade stuff so it like you can
jump on someone immediately assassinate
them and loot them all just with one
button pressing like cool it's so
satisfying and I like the idea that you
know as you with the leveling system
you'll come up on enemies that are hot
you know two levels higher than you and
you can't
yes fastening them right you you can do
the assassination move which hurts them
takes a lot bigger than you gauge in
battle when I've been grinding because
these games out grind email to which is
like the thing that you would never
expect in a way that's that's still fun
I will like go assassinate someone who's
two levels higher than me then hide then
go back
do it again stab them twice and it'll
kill them but it's hotter and it just
like adds this extra layer of challenge
mm-hmm I find it really fun to go to the
I don't know the coldness house is great
basically outpost yeah like it [ __ ]
right what are they called BAM became
something bandit camps of some of them
and some of them are like fortresses but
yeah you get the idea they like outposts
and you can go to ones that have several
levels higher than you just to see how
far you get and like just try and do it
over and over again to see if you love
them that's really really fun here we go
is this on the Xbox 1x yes it is
charis in Riedel says beyond you know
does the other character exist in the
story after picking the male or female
pair no spoilers what's the what's the
threshold for boilers I need to know yes
I'm actually better right there that
baby is the other cats ours
i ya know you just let you play one or
the other they're just like your avatar
if you will but they don't exist as
characters outside of that no that's not
correct they do yeah the same he's
always gonna be the other person yeah so
then you choose to be Cassandra the
baby's Alexia right and then if you
choose to be like Co the baby's Kazan
wait really
yeah I did not catch that yeah yeah well
they're just revealing any ever that
part yeah I was sleeping on that I mean
your first movie I mean depending on how
far you get yeah yeah
hey we'll see now I'm watching intently
I know right yeah I had my story man
yeah I want that cool stuff in this game
yeah I know like definitely miss that
and I think this is a lies to effects
this is was Adam Jensen I believe this
is one of the characters he played he
does a couple voices it definitely
sounds like him go I never asked for
this
it's like the only Adam Jensen wine I
really know that's what everyone says
are we going to see any of the modern
stuff here
you already did John yeah if you would
have been maybe just joined but yes I
think it might jump back again well
maybe not in this room usually it does
throw you into money stuff that I really
like this because it just like it really
does hi buck the Cyclops it's like yeah
hey this guy yeah yeah you powerful yeah
he rich see he's really mean the broken
man says is this DLC for AC origins or
is it just look alike hey my favorite
Daniel Pham ya know its own game
Assassin's Creed Odyssey and it's seven
ancient Greece it's awesome it's awesome
stop trying to hate it just enjoy it
enjoy video games people now you're
looking at the other mercenary I also
like this yeah reminds me of moto
talk to me about this cuz again I only
touched versions for a little bit was
this mercenary system in origins or is
this new here it wasn't okay cuz I do
think it's really cool that as it's like
the Grand Theft Auto bounty sister star
system right whereas you do more and
more bad things or people but you piss
people off they send out these Humvees
mercenary so they they had them in
origins they were called by lakes okay
but it wasn't like in the menu like okay
okay but they still would named they
were just like bosses that would be
around them all like so I keep I'm
trying to call you man I've tried hold
on it yet holy yeah oh you're right
don't worry I did it the first time I
did it is the exact same thing to you
let alone now you're trying to talk and
play game never easy the point yeah
first of all trying to use another it
does but I think the first time I did
that it also took me a long time to
figure it out though as well now the
final aches don't they don't they still
build them and it's like bosses that are
around the wall that you'll want to
avoid for a really long time and as you
get to that level you won't fight them
so that's that's similar but they're not
in the menu like that yeah they're just
on the map because yeah this mercenary
system is awesome and like the first
time I got it to where I had it really
high and so they sent three and I'd use
them at once it was like wow this is
like it doesn't happen it's an epic
battle that's happening organically it
wasn't you know like here I am getting
led into a boss fight it was like that
the whole time you like no they're happy
for you and you like aware of it but I
think one of the best experiences I had
with that in Origins was one of them was
looking for me while I was trying to
infiltrate a camp and so like I'm in
this camp trying to kill everyone and
then it shows up and is also looking for
me there it's just taken down one of
them and I immediately went to the bird
view and I saw them dispatch the next
one like it was like that organic and
like you can see in the real sense where
they're coming from the city center
that's cool yeah that's pretty neat keep
pressing why to dismount cause of GTA to
open the door yeah
hater says has great finish the game I
have none you'll see my sayin yeah we're
gonna be worried where's your say about
when we join that I want to say I'm
level 17 or 18 and that's like 18 or 20
hours something like that
very cool any levels are funny I mean
there's yeah level 40 stuff there but
when you pull out of the map I want to
say there's level 50 yup
oh really yeah when you actually look at
the map and see what's going on that's
pretty cool
for anyone who's missed the story right
now this is all pretty basic Markus who
knows like your second father bought a
vineyard with money that he doesn't have
but he owes you money CEO mad at him so
you're trying to get the money from this
guy who he had given money to that's it
but like even every NPC in the game
seems to just have a much more fleshed
out like we've done story so sure it's
cool are we gonna do a live play of Red
Dead - yes we are
just check-in follow us on twitter at
games pot and you'll know when we're
live fgc Linux I loved origins got 200
hours in it
yeah Zola Anders that's like all of the
little bitty side quests yeah in that I
mean what better way to talk to how
great much you love the game right yeah
let me to write the amount of people I
see who are like Hans I'd love to get in
I can't because I'm working so much yeah
I got dammit I think origins did a
really good job with like giving a lot
of content to people who just really
still wanted to play and explore the
game yeah was that like it was like a
exploratory mode eyford any my gosh
educate the education
the DLC yeah it was like a free DLC that
they gave Mike it's like right there but
I thought that was the coolest thing I'm
trying to be double evil I was hoping
that I could break all the stuff in
front of him and then kill him oh I
can't wait what if I do but I can't back
here oh I feel bad yes you should all
right you guys probably heard me like
smack for like hahaha I do I feel so bad
I even like watching you I'm not even
the one doing it and it makes me hate
you oh you were the one who said to be
evil yeah this is entirely on you yeah
it's scary to discovery just get
discovery discovery tour mode it was fun
well you're gonna hit me with that broom
really nah dawg now Michael Britten
interesting question would you offer
this yes I think this is a game of the a
candidate's done it's been such a good
year that's actually like a pretty big
compliment it's one of those I think
when I first started playing I was like
oh this is cool I don't know if it would
be but the fact that I'm so I can't wait
to play more and I really do enjoy the
story and I am enjoying leveling like
right I don't know I don't think it's
something you can ignore really I don't
think it'll end up being my game of the
year like full stop oh we got me dude
but it's kind of it has a lighting
chances oh sure Todd Ramon says I can't
wait to spartan kick you can unlock that
pretty early and it's a powerful move oh
look at first okay great I know I kick
some well as a knee as a bad person you
should be kicking as many people as you
can't have the cup yeah yeah I'm just
not cool enough to have want to kick at
this point got it God you can kick it
just doesn't it's not it's like not a
field kick
well baby kick
I really should have tried to kill
everyone but I didn't hear being evil
let's trick a person in here since that
assassin three Assassin's Creed 3 was
amazing that was my favorite one that is
my least family I was so into like the
colonial America like the revolution
thing that it just hey bud he's got a
red oh really
he's pretty brute alright I guess I got
away now I killed him it's weird hearing
these lines that I associate with
Cassandra not being spoken by her right
it's odd out of all the games which
should release in the last month
including a theodicy what games would
you say are the most essential play in
the last month it's a very like vitamin
- vitamin assassins it's Mario Party
today mark yeah all of them are good
yeah it's a good month yeah it's a
really good month
hey the singin who's that a month no
that might have been oh that was
and I was right it was uh well maybe it
wasn't it Andrea was talking but okay
yeah sure 2007 yeah
spider-man's awesome yes my mom is great
that they won't bring that it's been a
great games again Mike lost you in that
if every year is getting like this yeah
where it is there's amazing game for
amazing games like we don't have that
with movies right now it's like HM that
they not all just like kill oh we're
just like right now it's back to back
good game it is it's also the offseason
for movies - it's a little like the
summer he's always a little weird for
for films can wait for that Oscar season
yeah yeah it's always convenient really
that they release venom already you know
they were psyched they're so confident
right there I am so I was the naval
bases are very good fun I prefer them to
origins you were saying this before
earlier that this they really expanded
on yeah naval combat being back in the
boats great yeah like the way you
recruit people yeah the way you can
level it up which is funnily enough
reminiscent of Brotherhood yeah good
game doesn't seem like Assassin's Creed
it's making I hear that all the time
yeah evolved
I think the same stuff all the time what
do we be bored right it's funny because
when I feel like that's always the thing
right if it's to Assassin's Creed people
it's just a copy of the you know clone
game over over again but now that
they're actually doing something really
different now it's people are gonna be
like it was great I guess like that is
what I think of is when I think of
Assassin's Creed is like the assassin
logo yeah and like hidden blade yeah
right like you don't have those yet and
so it's like I get it it doesn't feel
like as identified right I think all the
combat being all the gameplay being
different and having evolved would would
make more sense if it was like more
tight and no more but mm-hm I'm also not
against it like you man give me
different stuff yeah I think that the
evolution is like refreshing and getting
new things with each game is keeps it
keeps it interesting yeah you know
everything away I can't protect you
forever like like your time with these
lines that are tossed Cassandra's lines
yeah I'm still delivering them really
well like I really get that relationship
between them he's delivering them
differently though yeah like some of the
emphasis is different right you feel
like the personality the character is
different you yeah yeah no dramatically
because the same same stuff but it's
it's Prancer oh yeah oh yeah this has
like an investigation pot gene start you
impressed that you see three and a see
liberation remasters are included in the
season pass I didn't know that I didn't
pay attention oh yeah well now I am now
you know I don't know you know this was
a question that was asked earlier but
I'm gonna ask it again cuz they probably
came in a little later there are two
types AC games since origins and
honestly came out which would you
recommend for a new player previous
games or new assassin screen names oh is
that like a division between its legs
and Odyssey all origins on and origins
back yeah the thing is here we go this
is the thing everybody here's the thing
they they didn't remaster them but I
think the gameplay of the original
series is kind of aged out yeah that's I
don't know that they would control so
well anymore this is a modern game right
this has all the trappings and things
that people want right now in modern
games
totally if you were going to recommend
one of the new and one of the old what
would you do you think oh man it's hard
because I haven't played the old ones
again like in a long time right so it's
like I love Assassin's Creed 2 and it
has one of my favorite endings in any
video game ever but I don't write yeah
it was such an awesome moment yeah
anybody I mean no I mean I would go
Black Flag from the old game so I have
you that's so close to being modern
it really has been like they're pretty
smooth transition smooth sailing say yes
everybody that he's really just right
there he's right just right there I was
gonna avoid him yes shrieks corner
currently Ilana is playing on xbox one X
and about and about we're gonna switch
over to Greg come on we're motoring is
this thing it's called about 10-15
minutes and we're gonna be playing on
the ps4 us he's picking up about 15 to
20 hours into the game so like that
something like that will see you'll see
the save one actually you wanted where
you at boy he's so close I feel like I
just need to he's gonna you got it wrong
me you can do it you got the skill no I
don't you're a lot of fun I don't got
this if I think if I just go through the
story that I he'll be like oh you
talking to someone
I won't kill ya just walks and like
stands behind you like sharpening the
boys she's in the back of the cutscenes
I'm really excited to jump into your
save Greg because I want I want to
romance some people oh sure
like I said there's I think we talked
about it I was talking a lot about it
there's a side quest that I know the
ending to will end in sex but we didn't
do it so when we get there we're gonna
put on right before this I use huge
credits and got the God of War outfit
I'm talking about oh yes and we are
gonna go get whatever this woman needs
nice to make love whatever she need
whatever she needs as Kratos this game
spot after dark eyes I think he's right
behind me
I think as soon as this leaves oh really
yeah oh hey bud hey there hey friend oh
now I love to bear now you got it's fine
do you guys play mostly on ps4 Xbox one
mmm I totally am split really yeah
whatever I got a coat on alright
I'm wait I'm to invest in PlayStation
trophies
- yeah I have a ps4 so that's where I'm
at I saw people earlier asking if I was
gonna try to platinum this I would love
to I do not have that kind of finished
persona five for you yeah yep yep I like
this question
we've had this much before booty ass
again
does Alexios exist in the world if you
choose cassandra oh yes it does they
bolt it's vice versa
yes hm they do exist and my mind was
blown because I missed that yeah so
that's awesome before anyone gets mad
about spoilers that happens very early
on in the game
somebody says the level of music sounds
a little like The Witcher yes yeah we
drew a comparison as well in our we chat
video
can you spartan kick out I'll be able to
Greg yeah hey what I'm good to see you
Joseph wacky weirdo bought Hewitt's
credits you're supporting
microtransactions in $60 games Greggy
for shame no man not for shame at all
actually
hey I'm first off I prefer disclosure I
got a code from Ubisoft for it and you
do earn some early on here but even if I
wasn't know you're supporting developers
oh yeah you could play the entire game
without doing any of the micro
transactions but I thought the God of
War cosmetic outfit would look cool
right bought it to support a game I
really really love yeah you're enjoying
the game for you it's fun to have the
new outfit yeah just want to laugh it
I'm the same way I my mice mice team
spend history is yeah well embarrassing
yeah a little bit same with was a huge
League of Legends choir and I own too
many skins for that game yeah no gems
for a days for me with it yeah like I
was like I got skins I can't I can't I
don't do microtransactions at all
I also had an anti DLC policy stance
yeah I was like I'm not doing either of
them not doing it and then which is
three bloodwine happened Cory bar log
isn't the chances there's god or there's
a God of War outfit there might be
saying where you wrap some chains around
you get some red stuff I'm sure that
exactly you go don't call shoe heck keep
Sony and Playstations lawyers out of
this you know we're probably sold the
game on it cuz I saw he was tweeting
both of us about like yeah he's gonna
pop in see if he's gonna get it it's
probably out you get it
we've clearly sold them on it now yes
excellent gameplay all this talking and
Colin's been great
all right I think that I forget my spot
and kick and how there you go yeah
can I like see this beard be customized
I think we know it's all cific I don't
think so I mean like there's just no
like I didn't option I think you can
make a case for a man
oh that NPC looks jankier this that the
other I think facial animations for
Cassandra I can only speak to you really
is cuz I've played so much with her yeah
great
yeah yeah I think that part of that is
that they lock it in I'm like she always
at that side ponytail right no no I go
it's so long before I would agree with
that wholeheartedly here here yeah okay
huh
the motion carries mm-hmm this is weird
to me this eagle mode thing used to make
a sound in origins and it doesn't yeah
right now it doesn't he's so close I
think I should just do it and he's died
of course his kudos Greg love supporting
the doves Cory you're the one trying to
sue them right now
get out all right also hi Cory thank you
for coming to the chat also I blame Cory
we did a game of four not any golf
attack yeah how you doing and Cory came
up with the idea that whoever won would
get to change the other people's Twitter
handles it's so Scott Lowe from Naughty
Dog one meaning that he gets to change
my twitter handle Cory's handle and she
was so it's like the Last of Us to ities
like it was too great with a year like
crap like that I gotta put everyone's I
hate PlayStation exclusives yeah that's
I do know that about thank you he killed
me with one hit we only hit me one time
oh my god it is a pressing wait don't do
that wait till you level five you can
actually do I found with those you can
do it one level lower than them but
anyone that knew you stickily cut it
guitar tips for Japan case you're
wondering Hot Tips
not warm tips just hot only hi this is
Linda right off the grill tips yeah
straight over the girl tips so I'm
really hoping that we can kick somebody
off of class so I can find someone to
kick Destry and have them like tasty
I'll try the buddies that happen
organically so far have you encountered
any side quests that you really liked or
oh that wasn't one that I was sort of
approaching that I'm not going to
because this guy patrolling the streets
where the temple in the town is like
trying to find this hidden spear and
they're pretty open about it they're not
like oh it's a spear that has been
hidden for centuries so like yet people
that give us cash if we got that spear
so right yeah yeah so they send you off
to find it and yeah you just used to
hunt it down it's kind of a stealth
mission to get in there and then right
you talked about like the choice at the
end right of like you can give it to me
why do them you can kill it like any
money yeah except I keep the speed
yourself if you want to uh I think my
Vista it's an early one it's coming up
we will get to it right now but there's
one in here where you go to a part of
town we ran through it but we don't have
a question where you basically there's a
plague there's this family that may or
may not be infected then you get there's
like the guards are confronting them
we're gonna kill them so you get there
you have to hear both sides and pick if
you agree with the guards or if you read
the family and then there's actual
ramifications from there that'll happen
later on in the game it's like that's a
really cool thing and it's not I don't
think it's not a black and white choice
okay this is the good one this is the
bad one it's like really what do you
want to do here yeah that's cool it's
especially cool kiz' is just such a
thing that that you never would have
thought the Assassin's Creed series
would have do you remember like in those
all the games you used to desynchronize
for like doing something they don't like
you exactly did you kill person you
killed
[Laughter]
let's see if I can spot a minion Ilana
you're going to keep the sphere or in
you a bead Bend alas I don't have to I
haven't gotten this baby yeah you know
the bad guy
patrolling do the choices affect the
story much I don't suspect so but I
don't know no wait sorry guys oh I was
just gonna say it seems like it clearly
affects your dialogue with with NPCs but
it doesn't necessarily impact any like
big ending I don't think there's a true
line story will be exact yeah I keep
comparing it to what I've seen it's how
I always talk about telltale games is
that we're all given the same coloring
book page but we all color in a
different way and shade it to make it
our own and so you should in it's still
the same image but we all have a
different reason what we did and how we
did it right because it is like there's
one mission that we definitely won't get
to that's pretty cool on a story one and
it's yeah do you want to kill this guy
or not kill this guy and I was like well
I'm not gonna kill him right which meant
that I went to the guy who sent me to
kill him and I still gave him his helmet
I was like I killed him so it's like I
still gets you that poem means bored it
means something different to me than it
would be like Kevin who I know killed
the guy yeah totally classic Kevin yeah
killed the guy
he keeps the I in his house is pretty
fun Spartan kicking after this cutscene
and then work yeah we can't do it I can
go buy it just for you guys - oh no this
place on this one I can spot you don't
ya just like two minutes cool well
switch it's totally cool if you can't no
there I was like I'm mostly joking by
mental training an area it will be
someone on a roof okay fine there's like
no like really just like my I'm just an
imposing my will I just want to see I
just like want to see I do it I respect
that you know you won't see that one
really badass Spartan moment yeah
satisfied lose audio okay he's going
he's done okay hopefully you guys have
audio where am I supposed to go it's
they so we have question you know which
mode is better to play traditional or
exploration exploration this is like a
good sign anything right where you're
like alright find this like way to go
Cyclops was on this island his home is
the west of the cursed value of
whatever's right there in the I should
be in the Cyclops layer so thank you
right there so yeah an every psyche
waffles what the cool thing about the
exploration mode is it kind of like
really makes you learn the map and its
makes more interesting to learn in the
map well I use it like I just you die
cones off so it will have question marks
yeah there are locations it can make a
lot easier but I just turned it off then
so it's like you make it even hotter you
like yeah I don't know where even any of
the locations up see that's interesting
I like my X's on that's why I was joking
around about I got a long I'm still
gonna question right yeah yeah tell
knows I think it's I think it's cool cuz
you're not a hardcore I think it's
really immersive which is cool yeah if
you're somebody who likes really linear
like oh you want to be told where to go
and what to do probably not for you if
you're not somebody's like into the open
world sure feels yeah it's still winning
a game but yeah if you just like want
direction I think that makes again for
shoulder we right right
I don't live there you know right I want
to live it is nice it's pretty beautiful
I just want to live all right
without the game audio in here it's
gotten real this is a shadow of what I
say you'd think they do I go you say to
you there's any things that I know about
an Internet chat kind of funny best
friend woody Jiang says he's a 100%
playing in guy didn't vote faster and
easier and that's the choice you're
allowed to have video games make him
yours definitely all right you made it
to the site is this has grindy as
origins this is I think it's about the
same yeah yeah
we're ears pardon - you fight mythical
creatures and stuff that's the rumor
I haven't yet yeah so I don't know I'm
you know what about 20 hours in is were
saying I have not run into that but I'm
not just qualifying because I didn't
seem to do sent a trailer but I don't
know what that means all right there yes
there's hints for sure yeah yeah there
you go
no they do not have audio No hey not
here so I'm being good about it thanks
for the channel we said no and he left
and he just turned off the audio audio
left with him up here yeah okay I have
one of these boys okay boy kick one of
these boys all right
let's kick just kick one of those boys
I'm gonna kick one of those boys we're
gonna go quick kick one of those ways
guys I got a dumb question I'm saying it
right boys I got no gas turbulence yes
virgins what I found is you know playing
a ton of this is that I really ask you
those questions off camera yeah okay I
thought you said a very different one
okay so I think I know the word you're
talking about hey can you climb is
easily everything in origins as you can
this because like I think climbing's
about the same because it kind of gave
me like that breath the wild feel that I
was like oh here we go take this boy
kick that BAM
boy right into the crispy no you know
what
the students all me it's like okay okay
this is a new thing I think some of them
have like and he does like different
types of errors like his oh yeah it's
like poison poison arrow all right so I
think I think we're gonna get ready for
a squawk here call me Joe killing
Richard for a swap richer to the room
Richard we're gonna swap so watch you
the ps4 for Greg so he can play oh well
we're fullscreen guys oh there's like no
more people it's fine it's straight to
full screen um so Greg do you know let
the this is a good time for me to be
like hey guys if you are just joining us
we are playing Assassin's Creed Odyssey
fill Ilana Pierce Hey and Greg Miller
hey if you guys have any questions I'll
be reading the shaft so let us know
what's up we were just playing on xbox
one X and we're gonna swap over to
Greg's game save got you loose you know
gamer muscles right you know on we're
gonna swap over to his save Greg do you
can give us a little bit of where you're
at in the game without spoiling too much
yeah
oh here I was in the brain sorry there
you go
[Music]
there where we are so here you go
I mean you can see level 17 that's where
we're at okay and you can see I mean
I've investigated go I've gone in I
would say in terms of story beats I'm
into the waxen you know what we look at
trophies I don't think they'll spoil
anything for you
everybody look away if you did until I
know if it's gonna spoil free but I just
did chapter for our episode 4 right so
that gives you a better idea who won it
and these are like the main parts of
what's going on in the story and I think
in origins that were like 8 or 10 yeah I
would say you know hidden trophies here
like there's like that many right so
there's that one but the one that was
probably like a free one in episode 9
plus the epilogue actually I got nine
episodes in I'm telling ya I'm gonna try
to beat Italy beat the story this
weekend I think you can't tell my
girlies a new sign see I'm down here and
you won't work oh yeah you know before
me for the like I said I got for Corey
bar log out there we wouldn't got we got
warlike outfit so let's we toss that
though see bad got my warrior restraints
it really is that's pretty awesome just
a lot of different skirts
I like these Kurtz what's your favorite
scary coats you know I'm I just let them
all go I think you just have some pocket
skirt that was a really good that's
pretty good a Spartan renegades site
here I have my Savior
hey oh you can toggle it - oh yeah of
course because I like I like seeing her
facial animation so much that I don't
you know he is so much cooler than mine
man I mean why would you say that easy
origins but with a different mapping
gameplay would you say this is like AZ
origins both a different mapping
implement yes and so it's like yeah it's
similar I don't think they're even
trying to hide that map is is kind of a
similar size it's more populated in this
I think it's a little more dense
gameplay has evolved but yes they are
undeniably similar all right this this
has more in it than just it's it feels
more than just like DLC like it is I
guess you should just awkwardly pass it
between by hands for this whole stream
oh I've been infiltrate oh we still
won't sound up here yeah yeah I don't
know okay cool ah super hard mode that's
cool outfit yeah right
that's um he says they don't mind minor
spoilers well we're gonna try to stay
away from all spoilers because they're
definitely people who care about them so
we're gonna with Greg's am do some side
quests right right now we're taking on
this mercenary yeah and when you don't
if we can take a look at your skill tree
and see if kind of have you built it out
it's Church and up to this point I'm
Jerry hits that first thing yeah yeah I
think the dodging is gotten a lot better
as well I like the X to dr. longer is
really cool yeah like that last-ditch
effort of like throw yourself away no
not you lady why why when we're battling
would you come here oh now she's pissed
too oh lady it ain't about you right now
look up she is a high-level in here
I'm gonna 1717 what about you
specifically as level 17 this dude was
only 16 look at him what a schmuck
- that's the flourish that you just use
and it's worth noting that you can see
the abilities in the bottom left but
they have a charge time as well so you
can't just keep spamming them yes and
yellow thing underneath that you are you
fill in as you actually yes apparently
it took me a little while to get used to
the like holding that l1 and I don't see
like that's not sure it's a it's an
unusual way up
mhm is the ship combat worthwhile I saw
something earlier right talking about in
there like hey I don't enjoy the ship
combat mhm alright I find a tiresome
already what I enjoy so far about this
is that you're really not forced into it
like there is traversal in it or
whatever and look but you can run for
most battles and I'm not feeling like
I'm not getting what I want out of it
but alright so you wanted to see my
ability yeah let's take a look and it's
like I live in I'm assassin more right
because you see like go on go over here
to long inventory account you see that
you have different ratings stuff - hey
for what damage you're doing so I like
doing all the assassins stuff but I feel
like I'm playing this in the general I
got these were the ones I really needed
right and now what you've leveled up
three times exactly there's one ability
that you can have but you can keep
adding your ability points to it so it
basically just gets like a better but
just about one thing look like that many
skills it is a lot of oh yeah yeah like
I've doubled up on bulrush already right
cuz I like that this healing ones super
helpful
can you yeah you explained with the
bulrushes sure that's one you just saw
alright as I basically you can see it
right there you step back run at them
with the spear and your sword or
whatever other weapons you have it also
lets you map them yeah yes one which I
like to write if you look down here yeah
if you look over to the bottom right you
see the fact that I have them down there
on the square across circle cool and
then this is another one the shield
breaker I thought was you start getting
into more and more shield guys like you
can hard strike them to open them up and
then this one's just so helpful be able
stab their shield hit him in the face I
can always rode yeah that's super
annoying that's very cool yeah and I
like it it's better than having to like
try to figure out a way to get behind
them or like you
yeah yeah um okay so here's what I want
to do are what do you got yeah it's all
good
I was gonna go over here where to
synchronize this point cool as we go to
whatever we find in the way we find the
way maybe we should grew up we messed
this guy run see what's going on over
here
cool and then afterwards running to go
get that stuff back that way the lady
needs for the lovemaking oh yeah before
I it's the only thing you agreed to the
string I'm sorry Greg's gonna do what or
I don't
yeah what kind of shenanigans are we
gonna get into what kind of once you got
I went for the one that could walk on
like the edges and stuff because III did
not like in origins the horse combat
yeah so I was very much like I know I'm
gonna be more of in the back Explorer I
like the middle one which is speed okay
so I was climbing and the other ones
battle I yeah I don't know I keep trying
to the whole combat even well yes Daddy
yeah I don't think you did something
yeah we're we're with you
yeah I got it okay well as long as they
have it it's fine it's on you you're
you're off to shenanigans don't ask why
you were aware see him doing it no it
was it was completely on its it's oh
don't you did something we're aware he
did some magic yeah what he's got a
controller in his pocket
oh no see you know it's back there not
having the audio of the people listen oh
she got we at homes it's and also now he
fix it it's gonna get real loud some
rush it back down
nope nope nope big now I'm gonna back up
some it's fine it's not yes we are just
concerned maybe the chat didn't but I
think they do so it's all good
something that you I want to know does
this feel like an assassin's Creed game
stuff yeah I mean your assassinate
available for either your climbing and
you're synchronizing I think it has all
those assassins tropes yeah I don't mind
the whole like a little bit animus stuff
that you know you do you something
you're fine so yeah it still feels like
it's still when climbing you know it's a
lot of the colors are there the one
thing that I miss the most is I love the
tombs any all the games right to be like
yeah there was like awesome gear I miss
I miss those but yeah it definitely
still feels combat
similarly comics been greatly improved
but it's more involved now whereas it
used to be just like kind of wait for a
line of people and then kill them all in
a row
crime wants to know Greg yeah did you
have any challenge did Greg had any
challenging levels during his
playthrough so did you encounter any
serious challenges so far yeah I mean
it's when you get into an area I think
that you shouldn't be in yet where
you're dealing yeah or it's multiple
people or you know like there's a guy
higher level and then there's all these
little guys you're working with and
stuff like that that's when it I think
the game really steps up and like I was
saying over that's why the level systems
cool there because you can decide to do
that it doesn't it's never like you're
not high enough level you can't do this
feel like you want to do it yeah exactly
I'm gonna try to go in there that's the
thing of like when I you know after this
will jump to the map and zoom out and
when you see stuff that is like yeah
this is level 46 like alright cool I am
NOT going there destroy me and we do it
when you do try to do it you know I just
get to gosh yeah well since I've done
that
that was a bad move on my part wait hold
on say like you pour the way out right
over here you're stop seeing stuff 25 20
whatever but then up here in the top
corner is like yeah
4650 well yeah I mean like it's like
super high level so spam is
it's 50 the highest then like that for
highs I've seen yeah does this game have
a photo mode I greatly enjoyed noticing
it while playing horizon zero dawn it
does it sounds like something you just
said Greg I love it all right so we have
to go to the northern part of Grand
partisans grandma GRANDMONT poneslas no
Passons for you are there tornadoes in
this game I have I don't see many
tornadoes
I got a Just Cause situation
is this assassins creed 300 addition if
you like a movie 300 yes it is I will
enjoy this yes
oh that's why I'm mentioning too is you
don't really need to synchronize anymore
but it unlocks faster up the point okay
exp yeah yeah how much is it what's that
you got to feel like you got to do it if
you see him there you got it be nice to
climb usually yeah you'd see like nice
Vista yeah mm-hmm I was talking you know
though to the game spots Lucy James and
she was talking about she kind of missed
the idea of the old synchronization
points was kind of like a puzzle
like how do you get a whereas now it's
very much like wow basically nothing is
actually you don't have to have any
strategy with the the terrain or the
buildings at all it's kind of just like
if it exists you can climb it yeah yeah
it looks like I totally echo that I
missed the climbing puzzles just in
general
yeah and I'm with you to that I missed
like the old wolf spins that it was like
you had going there yeah I think like
the older games they had that like Tomb
Raider ask element to exploring the
world climbing the you know just
everything was yeah a lot more Tomb
Raider you know it's just supposed to be
like get through it easily which makes
it more accessible yeah yeah it
definitely does but it kind of lost that
like that oh that finally I'm out there
like jumping into a haven sure huh
if they ever got rid of that I would be
like alright hold up you have gone a
quest to what at this game ever wasn't
important question does Greg like I bet
you might I know I don't I don't need
that it's fine thank you
okay good rollin same page yeah
Gulfstream can continue if you guys are
just joining us we are playing
Assassin's Creed Odyssey which is out
today and the stream is brought to you
by Ubisoft right now Greg is playing on
the ps4 Pro peaceful pro and he's about
15
level regret we're level 17 mm-hmm yeah
well I can tell you that exactly here
oh you don't that's it's too late no the
kids want to know anyone throw in my
face
yeah 19 18 hours in sweet yeah how do we
know that your wife didn't punch you
guys this is this interviews over
she's too busy playing sorry that's a
question that just got askew romance a
whole loss no no don't think so don't
think yeah remember mr. ed though mr. ed
miss Chi says the horses are all the
same Jess actually really likes they are
not gonna say oh they're different a lot
of me there's a unicorn in this game
cosmetic that'd be cool cosmetic unicorn
unicorn I'd go for it I think you have
to buy it that's real money yeah I do it
I would do it Hey yes take me there
so your super moves are gonna be more
are gonna be more useful later on
against multiple enemies question mark
no I think they're always useful they do
extra damage and like as you're in
combat you build up a meter so you can
use them they're just they're like extra
heavy attacks I would say but they do a
variety of different things so some of
them are useful in certain environments
like kicking someone off a ledge can
kill them you can knock people into each
other like they have different uses so
yeah but it's it's not a multiple
enemies things they're always just kind
of useful
it's like Ghia in spider-man or like
that might not gonna be able to having
me something else you can use totally
yeah right now focusing on the main ones
I have alright this is a good thing and
this is a good starting point I just
want to max those out as much as
possible
first fastest oscillations I guess we're
gonna kill some deer or to help this
lady snowy up there do you know
something is there any differences
between the xbox version and the ps4
version I don't think so yeah I like
that's that one thing while you're
playing on xbox 200 that's a babysat
Xbox too I thought
[Laughter]
are there more romance paths with women
or men I mean you can romance anybody
yes I'm not sure so far so far it's one
for one I've had sex with a guy I've had
sex with a girl and now I believe it
might be an orgy the territory of fear
oh it's a bit out of your horse so this
is an origins as well what I have it's
literally called a lab and it's like the
ideas that you'd go in about - if I
thought that the animal and then you
have a boss fight with the big version
of that animal
yeah it's a good way for getting
supplies that's a big boy I hate that
they just get coming in boy
he he's well animated they've got a real
bear into the mocap studio right now
someone fight him like he has different
moves it's cool
oh he's okay he's bad guys legs he's dug
no no it was that guy who slowed down
yeah I did a perfect dodge or whatever
nice
no big deal guys just perfect
suppressant I want your Daris are you so
aggressive like will it really
oh my god the Bears going after my horse
just keep coming
they're all the - real attack of the
horse what happened this is what you
should have gone combat [ __ ] combat
doesn't have to protect himself calm
Bowers kickin up man he looks after
right now yeah he's not having a great
day do you read any other two bears go
there's chasing down my horse can you
use your boner I could but I feel like
they get it like these are gonna be more
powerful attacks
feel like you can just get like really
can fall be falling back there pretty
quick though that's the issue the Bears
are like that you hit those Oh Oh [ __ ]
I suppose yeah that's funny it's almost
like the main button yeah if you can if
you can foam in the mid side you'll miss
them up right quick but it's called it
there we go
alpha bear down alright only three left
we're doing oh no no we are not playing
on PC we are currently playing on the
ps4 Pro and the game is out today on
Xbox one ps4 and PC Thank You Nick I
don't if I might start nothing no they
are gonna attack me nothing excellent
and yeah it's so good yep that is really
satisfying
rekt alright so no no no everybody yeah
what do you get from the Bears look at
that position
yep he's like he's quite then quite dead
hello veteran G why did you think that
would be D here it said ok the bag
righto well it said I gotta go to the
north here if he said if you go up here
to the north you have them out you find
them maybe that I bet they may be that
final one will be in there yeah but we
instead we're to go into the background
and maybe there are some deer in here
what do we know we have all this stuff
look at all those stuff they had any do
yes Pez got a real living room decked it
out
the spoils of war with a bear
I actually like that they even set it up
for why does lose another little ankle
there's looting that because clearly
someone else was in town on their return
yeah it's cool oh hey puck you Ben
Affleck class aw no exact what I did
it does look exasperated he's about it's
it's cool as well because it really like
sometimes these guys can be part of a
story mission too like there's they're
part of a scripted fit they just really
like build them up as being young
nemesis yeah that's pretty cool like
you'll be walking around the world and
be like oh well I don't know how to
pronounce his name good
[Music]
chuckles around that man is there a
non-combat history learning mode like
blasts Assassin's Creed also is there
dolby atmos I think there is a learning
thing though I'm not sure if it's in
there yet okay we haven't looked
honestly yeah I haven't seen or heard
about the non-combat mode I think that
the last one was very well received for
origins and so I would hope that they
come out with one if they say haven't
you yeah so yeah damn you got on the
hill in your die you thinking what you
did down there no Greg is basically
Goldilocks question mark that's true
that is true I did that's funny
and I thought that that's a good job I
see FASFA you guys I get jokes whoa what
do you guys know about the dlcs story
nothing
yeah very little nothing yeah I played
it anything oh my god what that tells
him though it doesn't matter now that
bear it's just like before now the bear
wants to start crap with me I wasn't I
already killed the alpha bear to kill my
horse the chaos I love when NPCs by MTV
I know it's so funny I just I enjoy it
so much
greatly entertained by it it's so good
yeah you really make everything in virga
is that it's so good alright what do
y'all think about the new ps4 Ally
controller Wow the scuff one mm I think
so even with the offset sticks and all
that stuff yeah that's what I prefer
offset stick so I'm just a mom favorite
that I don't think would be weird but I
totally get it alright no console wars
guys we play it on both the Xbox one and
the ps4 pros that's exactly we can all
agree as console players PC is the real
enemy and needs to be stopped you're not
wrong he's not round must be stopped
yeah ruining gaming
but yeah if you guys are interested in
seeing it on Xbox one you can rewind the
stream or we're gonna publish this pod
so you know it'll be there and you can
see a lot of playing on Xbox one in
Spartan can go back to that moment where
I thought Greg said a word that he
didn't say that I keep chuckling about
see if you can guess what I heard
I'm pretty sure like yeah I thought I
was right on the money with what I
thought you said or what you thought I
thought no but then you said no I didn't
think I know what you thought I don't
know what I think you thought I said
yeah man we've all been that uh through
the head got it
you know we'll be fun to mike says
senpai notice i explosive barrel it is
your desire arrows sorry I forgot how do
you switch you hold this and then
yeah I got oh that's a knockout there no
I've not got arrows
I got like I'm like I'm green arrow at
the end of a long fight right have like
the joke arrows like yeah that'll do a
few 100 1d this is not also on Twitch
queers only streaming on YouTube in site
right now
oh and Twitter if you're watching us on
Twitter guy down there's like I said I
just did my friends blood just splatter
all over my thing no matter how hot a
man dying oh no Mike I have the leap
assassination go how long is this game
just over 50 under 60 hours about I
guess 50 to 60 you like fully mainline
the story it's probably around 40 but if
you like take a little time it's
probably 60 right how do you guys feel
about the change to the loading screens
we talked about that we missed the
running but it's so quick now that like
the loading screens is so fast that you
kind of don't even notice them yeah but
I do prefer the running do you ever
think there will be an Old West
Assassin's Creed game hmm
not while Red Dead is yeah which it will
be for the next eight years yeah I would
agree
huh next one maybe so probably could do
it but I don't I don't know I think that
that's a tough sell to do anytime soon
yeah yeah you gonna let that ride and
again just make the Japanese one thank
you what is that we would want cuz it's
been going with mythology now as well
yeah I'm trying to think of like other
settings yeah probably something like
you know Mayan or Aztec some type of
like Native America is Georgian that
could be cool
I'd be into that I love like Mayan
mythology the stuff is so cool yeah cuz
like I mean I'm shadow Tomb Raider kind
of delved into that and it was it worked
pretty well for them I think yeah
totally well Greg be able to finish
before Red Dead - that's a big concern
and that's why I like clear my schedule
get there I don't think I can
I don't think I'll be able to I think
I'll just be okay it's like it's
honestly a fear because I really love
the game like I really do want to see it
there that's what I'm saying is that I
just main line at this week oh man it's
something I want to do myself and you
gotta like the 20-plus hours you know if
you guys are just joining us we are
playing Assassin's Creed Odyssey we're
on Greg safe he's playing on the ps4 Pro
and we're about 18 hours in and we're
trying to go and find some deer yeah if
I'm if I'm what cuz we need the jingle
to get the love of dates yes we're
trying to romance somebody right now
we're trying to find some why does she
do that she's trying to make viagra for
like her husband it's weird yeah well I
think it's like you know pheromone oh
yeah yeah you know I'm not a pharmacist
I don't know what goes into my I agree
ancient Greece ancient Greece doesn't
make sense but it's fine it's cool if
anybody in there is gonna in if if I'm
getting colder for the dear let me know
in the chat I need your help Greg can
you speak a little bit to some of the
skills this the be elevated skill tree
that I think the skills skill tree has
evolved and improved a little bit since
origins I guess we do a compared to
origins but I can't speak to it here
like right we were talking about it
earlier in terms so when you level up
you get the skill point and then you go
into your abilities and you can apply
them to bunch of different ways and do a
bunch of different things you can see
like I found the skills I liked right so
I started buying them and like here
Frechette but you know I loved
assassinating people I made sure i maxed
that out you know I feel like right now
my revelation ability or whatever the
you know where you hold the dying and
see things is good enough so I haven't
bothered spending stuff there right
earlier in fights I was like it was fine
but then you started going up against
tougher mercenaries it was like man
these are taking longer and I know I
need to get an offensive skill so I
chose the bull rush just so I could get
distance and attack and come back rather
than this spartan kick rather than the
heavy attack thank you I'm a little
disappointed you don't have a kick but
you know we know what it's okay you get
the game you're playing your way it's
true it's true I guess
later the deer it's fun to get to
customize where art is a way you mocked
it is that was just a random guess cuz I
was like I was like I wanna start moving
it's just in the northern part of where
the northern part of Grand Mountain what
if you uh pulley boat up and it's
canceled and you've been playing
Cassandra correct in a positive friendly
mostly positive yeah like I mean I it's
I like these games cuz you get to do it
on a case-by-case basis and yes I'd like
oh this is you know how I want to play
as her how I don't
who I want to go after and who we don't
want to go no need right thing here is
idea there's that a goat I think it's a
since great India would be cool tonight
is how that is that's made up
isn't there an assassin no there's no in
India yeah you know uh this is Russia
that's a chronicles mm-hmm I don't think
that's an Indian now they haven't kept
track of all the handheld ones yeah oh
yeah yeah that was the bridge too far
right
I played the PSP one what was that that
came out just off the to anything deer
right it was going back to higher it was
a crime there was chronicles India but
it was yeah is it a deal
no it's got antler it's still not back
still an ibex let me come on maybe like
is that picky yeah exactly
oh that's a speedy eye bags were you
going it is so funny like trying to
watch Greg not screen
now he's whispering I'm trying to I'm
hunting yeah so don't stall it
the ibex that we helped by a growing oh
yeah why did the I have that powered up
arashan thing no no I think it worked
he found the northern part of the Grand
Mount Parnassus that's where I am man
just to clarify there's been some
confusion in the chat Greg and Ilana our
guests today so we walk here now yeah
well I left kind of funny yeah that was
a fun house and Greg's what kind of
funny thing it's like north beyond well
you know it would tell you I mean I get
to keep moving back when we're just
trying yeah all right I would I would go
to all of the question marks cuz it's
gonna be a location it's gonna be
another kind of like the event yeah I
exactly
sorry ibex you're not good enough for me
just contributed to the cause and died
ding ding ding what size TV is Greg
playing on uh-huh 14 inches
yeah I suppose it's kind of far away
from us as the smaller thing once you
guys here gonna die sorry
whispers watch your head stop that
really close you gonna kill them
what I like level 15
that's chump change and I think you'll
be fine
these are different in the modern games
- and that you go to an outpost and then
it tells you location objectives I don't
think that maybe that happened in Black
Flag as well I don't know how far back
that goes but it'll tell you like there
are two like treasure chests that you
need to get and as they'll be generally
like a leader of the camp each killing
you all that good stuff
it just gives everything a CASL are yes
about rape
do you have the auto loot thing no I do
on a successful assassination ah that
guy I hit like a little sliver left
after I did it because I didn't do a
charge assassination gotcha I'm Swiss
let someone see everything he's a boy
yeah your polygon Oh I highly recommend
using the boat when plugable that's
great
yeah it seems good and you can get
really powerful bows and there even some
that have sort of different buffs I
think they're onto you they don't they
aren't really there's always one hundred
here huh what's that noise yeah they
give me fine
I know but I want to do it the cool way
that's okay continue as planned
Manesh
I feel like this is kind of even more
tense playing it without audio it is
like oh yeah highly recommended how
early on were you able to unlock that
one it didn't feel like it was really
far along look because I fast yeah I
think I got that me yeah it's right
there second level not that a lot of
what skills have you like favorites so
far I don't have the shield one I have a
health one and all three of the button
that abilities so I've got the spot and
cake the bulrush and I don't really make
other one but I've mostly been focusing
on both offensive attacks and healing
and less on environmental stuff an
assassin stuff so mm-hmm but it does let
you tailor it a lot and you don't get
your abilities that often so one cool
thing is that I'm always thinking about
what I'm going to unlock next to me I
know next time I want to get this and I
will usually like chase that and get it
so that's pretty cool it gives you
something to look forward to every time
you level up aside from just stat boosts
which is cool I just I love the loot
system I think more than anything like I
love Diablo and my boys like to mmo's so
it's similar to that it's like I'm
always just like oh what's the next look
that I'm gonna get in like what are its
stats gonna be right it's a lot of
management but it's fun decimal point
right is that you want to feel like
you're getting rewarded I think yeah I'm
get different things yeah you've also
got a lot of weapon variety like I
usually use just a single sword but
there you can see that you've got
daggers stuffs Spears so those all have
different play styles as well which
sometimes you swap them out like
sometimes if there's a enemy one of the
most scenarios they'll go to like a
heavy weapon cuz they're generally just
have like more HP back you know gonna
free that man
how does he pay attention yeah it was he
I don't think it was like you do the
whole thing you should probably that man
oh good look thank you man just killing
him right now don't do that no no for
you for you you want a death you want a
despair there it is okay I can't believe
you made me do that and no one will ever
have to like God knowing well I just
feel like you killed that dad you're
saying you killed that guy you're only
making it worse letting you know today
his blood is on your hands
he was so happy to be free he didn't
actually look that happy to be fat he
looks startled what's going on I thought
you were leaving me that was messed up
doesn't look like any deer and there my
dear I know yeah it's all unfortunate
how do you feel about the diversity of
landscape it's cool yeah yeah like this
felt different than are these islands
feel different than Elle and you started
on right and that was my main concern
when I started like it's all gonna be me
yeah like it's huge as expansive is it
gonna be diverse yeah it doesn't it
seems like there's different weathers in
different places there are beaches in
some and Rocky Mountains and others and
that obviously this water stuff soon
I wouldn't say like enormous ly diverse
but it's good solid water stuff I think
a lot of stuff mhm
do you want to do here alone anything is
because it's in the northern part of the
Graham does that mean that it's like
right up the the very talk this could be
a - you know yeah that's the thing
Oh like the top of the mountain yeah
maybe that's not it's not but I mean
that's more than mountain I guess what I
just put it down on let's go really give
it a shot whatever man where's here
killing people Sam's making us kill
humans that are savings that dude was a
slave that wasn't this he had a family
she wasn't looking forward to seeing
again Harold really worried about him
nice little cheese chef no he will be
remembered
no no but not forgotten
another one I'm lost yeah another one
for the pile uh did I miss the romancing
part no we're still there I'm sorry we
were trying to get fit so look at your
horse doing that mountain goats I'm
tellin you man that's what that's what I
wanted I'm getting into
I remember the horses in Assassin's
Creed 3 were like pretty janky it's like
it's coming to come up a long way here
now this is the Greg I know that was
mine you killed a man
sure yeah that is me all right well turn
crazy crazy uh yeah dear-dear
there's another guy you know me killin
PPT wants to know how much different is
different origins I just only see
origins I played this I feel like I
played this game already it's just the
same we've tried it over that a couple
times you know it dramatically like if
you are the kind of person who doesn't
have a budget to buy a ton of games
every year I would understand if you
played origins if you wanted to skip
this because that both long and similar
but it to me as a person who tries to
play pretty much every game it is
different enough that I'm satisfied so
it's like I like it
kind of depends how much you know what
you want I think if you enjoyed origins
a lot like the investment because it's
just so long yeah and put a lot of time
in totally there's a lot of bang for
your buck on it yeah yeah which I
definitely think it is it is distinctly
different but I can understand like if
you already feel that way
tell me oh you're injected ly wrong yeah
I think that there's definitely a lot
there to to play and the story is really
good in this yep definitely an
improvement
Oh got that cool assassination you see
that can do that nor is it yeah
right the most sensitive part I won't
kill him for you please no matter what
you say just let him go please
okay good he's gone he made it out gotta
find them dear
did you call those guys down that 2
lemmas
Oh who's this guy yes I see this lady he
won't sit here oh thank you
I finally inherit you first Canada you
know that's how that works right if you
kill someone on their property then you
leave me on it yeah okay
thought so do the dialogue choices and
choice of gender make it different well
it's hard to say before we both finished
it yeah it seems like the answers yes a
little bit we played right it was very
much that okay this feels exactly like
the same conversations we've had
yeah same Donna just you presented in a
different way yeah they sound different
but and they emphasize different words
so they they seem like a little sounds
different yeah I don't think the dial of
choices will affect the story mm-hmm
like the ending is going to end up being
the same but I suspect you've of Kratos
Corrie borrow are you still watching
he's here huh we just lose that became
great yeah we're gonna that's cool
you have to kill the clan chief is it
gonna be Kratos I mean if I should grab
it what is the best AC ever ever look
define best my favorite is Brotherhood I
also very much like Assassin's Creed 2
best is either this or origins I think
yes so far from my money is this one
heard of here folks
there you go breaking news yeah yeah
tweet it before this I would have said
black flag for gameplay in Assassin's
story yeah yeah that's probably why I
like those two the most honestly that's
human it's your daughter I think it's
also really good
it's your the third after ends there's
what do you think it is that sets apart
honestly from others in the Assassin's
Creed series is it just the setting
setting the characters setting
characters in yeah with the way they're
doing side missions the way they're
making the world actually feel have been
cared about
if an animal kills one of your quest
givers during a mission does the MP
series bond I don't have to assume they
do right yeah that'll they can't be
killed by an animal
I would guess they have some kind of
invincibility probably mmm a lot of your
quest givers are inside of yeah like
they're in cities like away from chaos
Alana can you narrate the game like Red
Dead 2 gameplay lady and here we can see
Cassandra climbing through the cave
towards her next quest objective it's
very disturbing thank you that was a
really good in Red Dead Redemption to
okay that's weird it's like watching you
with a different voice it's it's weird
for me to hear oh my god I sound like
that underwater navigation is a new
addition to the Assassin's Creed
franchise no it's not but it's fine
that's like very good standard American
accent thank you yeah early on games
daily when we're talking when the kid
right in yo career right very much like
oh yeah you're gonna some games that's a
lot of it some use whatever if you
actually have talents at it you're gonna
mean we're I'm just hired to be Greg
Miller you can actually do things about
that we'll see about that yeah that's
really good you're really going around
just like come up with a different
personality and I just I just like at
and brought a lot okay yeah I just pull
out a David Attenborough whenever I can
really cave of Kratos guys I also like a
good Michael Caine
okay okay no man
oh he a tough boy no house holding it
was hoping you just put your eye
together on their own very like the king
both laugh I know you all all of you I
watched a wolf kill my quest giver and
four hours later he still hasn't respond
any suggestions yeah pray pray say low
prayer probably someone you can email
about that yeah god they're all in fire
but they're still in second I'm going to
kill you
this is why you do the multiple saves
thing you know oh no I'm not gonna yeah
no you stop all the hell there's names
don't even Kratos it's a zoo it's the
cave of Kratos I bet we're gonna find
like fine Xena fine and a cave of Kratos
I bet like it's all the smart and stuff
with that but it's gonna be cool weren't
you getting here the cultists of cosmos
yeah you don't know about it don't look
doing every nobody look no we look at
that if you don't want to know stuff
with them just so you guys know we have
about 15 minutes left
flying through it I know so if you're
watching and you have any questions you
let us know
oh I'll pass them on ask them that boy
in a cult you reckon we never found the
data monetize this is how Kratos we do
is pretty cool I don't know who that is
but it's spooky it's scary
yeah I'm spooked
the concentrators it's called there are
cults yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I was
expecting to come down here find like a
tomb of Kratos just people look like
they've not you know Sun crossover like
well I think it's face paint
oh yeah there weren't this is my mom
yeah but they're blue the Robin they're
super spooky yeah yeah yeah not staying
away from the spook fact but see even
that's cool it's like a reason for all
these people to be together they've got
all their banners everywhere it's like
actually I washed out even though it's
just so many guys scary
rekt no I'm feeling I might put on the
hood oh I feel like we're in the kind of
mode - yeah exactly
out spooky I'm PJ - yes you can romance
any gender based on whoever you are so
if you were playing Lexie oh so you can
romance men if you're playing Sandra you
can romance women you can get day if you
want yeah super freewheeling back then
that is true I did really awesome true
yeah yeah I keep going back keep seeing
like Lothian other rocks
no but it's shiny I know I got it
collected who doesn't want some obsidian
glass have you read The Odyssey yes I
think we've I've read The Odyssey in
school I was in school we I don't
remember it well I don't remember Kratos
being in it but I'm stoked that he is
that this he's a good wood ooh this is
pretty
go towards the light I thought it was
snowy for a second I was like are you
gonna breath of the wild and make a pull
on you snug yeah ah
among seniors way too much they on
yourself I can't leave here just like
him Guam two more lutes to get here
before I finished off the cave of
greatness I want to find some reference
to aside from those sweet chain braces
yeah all right awesome that is not cool
how did you get it did you croft it'll
buy it
no that was from yeah you got used to
EULEX credits for us I see I do think I
might go back to the other chess piece I
was wearing them which was just like
gold with like the red scarf yeah I
don't I kind of dig that more but the
chains I got to keep the rest away I
like that you can upgrade it - it's like
you can you find a style you like but
even if you find a better piece you can
eventually you know if you want to spend
the resources on it come back and make
sure you keep the cool stuff do you get
set bonuses I think so yeah yeah I
thought that you did too but I'm not
sure pretty sure you someone give me
context for why the missions name is age
is just a number
Oh cuz the these are old people trying
to get it on so I'm trying to get them
to viagra yeah we're yeah baby trying to
get with the ball so it's quality is
what I believe happens is I get it for
her and then I'm like invited to join in
yeah yeah mm-hmm
like I want that I know that the street
hey someone can you look up where to
find dear please fight a deer probably
there's no walkthroughs yet game just
came out well yeah look it's out today
so I mean maybe I think it what no no I
mean like I don't likely aidan alumni of
kind of funny games do I know she did a
wiki guide for another company that
shall remain nameless that Ilan and I
have close ties to okay here we have one
more loot to find near okay there's
always a huge gathering of deer east of
Grand Mount Parnassus is the pokeo
region the poky region that's near
Ukraine wait no that would just be the
region on the map
wait are you kritis wait somebody's got
it where do they create us reference are
you critics alright so we got this is
this this is a completed all right we
did it you don't did the cave since
which are impacted development of the
origin though of the origins what other
game weather games Ubisoft might look
for that a lot of open world games are
going to take cues from brother while
and I continue to be shocked that more
games didn't take cues from shadow
mortal right yeah with another system
yeah 100%
it's crazy to me but I feel like there'd
be such fun ways to do that and not have
it come
it's a complete ripoff for anything
what's that Blanche working on man I
know they're working on just holes with
yeah I think that's the only thing that
we know mm-hmm cuz the Mad Max would be
such a good fit
oh no that what hang on rage too as well
right yeah that's right
I mean there's something yeah they would
be such a good fit for that system
that's this touches on it with the way
most scenarios what but it's not quite
exactly yeah it's not like they come
back for you right what a lot yeah if
you can finish the mission there are
some no we're at we're at we're at right
now it's a pretty what here did you show
me the photo mood it was so nice that no
back there oh we don't have fun all
right so we're we're like we what don't
you want to see the old people Peggy
you're right I do on the map here okay
it's like it's right here it's okay
that's all right now and we need to just
basically go here you're saying yeah
right maybe a little bit over yeah oh
right right right you're right there cuz
there's that divot all right cool we're
going yeah apparently there's deer there
hopefully cross my fingers old people
need to get it do it for them how are
they gonna get it without deer for some
reason yeah with that pheromone I don't
know the deer mouse passing hmm like
Panama's mmm Jim doesn't make sense but
it's time
calling it the boy this game has an
emesis light kinda know Joe a little
yeah it's well it's at the mercenaries
exist and they following you and pursue
you and they get it higher levels but
it's that's all scripted so it's like it
doesn't react to you which is what the
Nemesis system is Wow yeah not so good
now huh
hey you know what this great may be
awesome for the horse can I climb up as
well
Roach could have done it Roach would
have spawned I don't know how to get
down right how is the trophy list uh
it's not terrible it's but this is one
of those games that knowing how much
time we have till Red Dead and just how
much time it's gonna take to beat the
game period I really haven't gone fully
and on if I you know get there and I do
a bunch of other stuff and get a maybe
I'll investigate more but it's fine
they've been popping which depends
they've been popping deer deer deer deer
no there's one oh my god yes there's a
lot of them oh you got you I got another
one I hate that I feel happy about this
hey it's for having sex it's true you're
right it is what fist yeah see it's in
the name of love we're good here we go
everybody
hmm people gross yeah but their hips no
missing the fast job dude mmm say it was
hot keep the stream going you don't get
to peek what people want to see that was
a lot of love that I'm pretty pumped up
who is it your enemy this is the moment
we've all been waiting for
I hope it's worth it what I just like oh
thank you that's not always is like a
have you've seen the bank in addition is
very much like you want to bang in there
like yeah you and you walk in and then
you like it's like the fan feedback and
you walk out like we bagged like
excessive speed too had pretty good sex
scenes and then it would like lead into
them they were very romantic and then
I'm like fade out you just like wake up
in a hay bale or something
was implied here we go
[Music]
the one thing I'll say is I I struggle
sometimes where like your mission
objective like the the radar up there
shows like icons for other stuff and
question marks but when it does show you
like oh here's where you're supposed to
go yeah it doesn't put it on there and I
find myself sometimes like as colorful
as the world is getting it lost weight
where yeah I feel like you do need to
pay attention when you're playing an
exploration mode because if you aren't
paying it there's no one that's saying
you'll be like I have no idea what I'm
supposed to be doing on it here we go
but the bug can help you with that yeah
these people I'm gonna have sex with
Larry David looking good reignite a
spark my love I would see you're like
you let me do like him that we've been
through this I can't satisfy you
tomorrow we're going to kill me what
you're gonna kill me I don't I keep I
told you about new accent the vigor of
any man a fraction of your age god save
me I cannot do this anymore
there you go let me satisfy you ha ha ha
your husband's tired allow me to satisfy
your hunger that like she's a mercenary
she's very clear I'm very upfront about
what I am I was your guy get his vigor
on himself
oh he's got a man feels like good guy
Harry I'll just play this music I like
this passage of the show how long it's
going on Wow she is insatiable ladies
and gents the next day Wow
did she put that should hold her for a
few days
waste all right we wish I'd buy today
thank you for the to take this as
payment have fun don't kill you he's
like we finally it's not what I expected
that's so very nice of him that was good
that won't really I enjoyed last time we
did everybody
mission accomplished yeah mission
accomplished you know that means here
though alright so I think that is that's
it I think we're we're almost at that
time we're like two minute you know is
there anyone else you can come in a
minute I'm gonna bone this guy saya
killed this thing it finally can be very
hard yeah this stream started two hours
ago guys if you want to if you just
tuning in now as soon as this is over
that you can you watch the vaad it will
be there on youtube if you're watching
on twitter it is on youtube it's been
it's been real thank you yeah i feel the
question yeah we're here oh no i'm screw
being on camera if you guys are excited
to play assassin's creed honestly the
game is out now on ps4 Xbox one and PC
shoutouts you saw for sponsoring us
today and a big thanks to Alana and Greg
are you so much your own yeah thank you
for coming by and playing or put this it
was great having you and thank you guys
for watching and we'll see you next time
bye bye guys
you